[Music]
what I love about Nicole she is a mother
who plays really plays what I love about
Charlie he loves being a dad he loves
all the things you're supposed to hate
like waking up at night she knows when
to push me and when to leave me alone he
never lets other people keep him from
what he wants to do no it's not easy for
her to close a capra he's incredible Nev
she's brave he's brilliant she's very
competitive
[Music]
so I'll tell Charlie what's happening
and Cassie knew then hand to me and
below I just get nervous
can you unser what you mean like take it
back Charlie and I are getting a divorce
mom you can't be friends with him
anymore you know most people in my
business because transactions do that I
like to think of it was people oh okay
good
you remind me of myself on my second
marriage
what we're gonna do together is tell me
you were story you dye your hair again
well this is me
you don't like it is it shortened I
prefer longer but how are you doing I
realized I never really come along for
myself I was just being his aliveness
I'll never get to really be his parent
together he needs to know that I fought
for him
[Music]
it's not as simple as not being in love
anymore eventually they'll be the two of
you having a figures help
[Music]
together
if we start from a place of reasonable
and they start from a place of crazy
when we settled will be somewhere
between reasonable and crazy
[Music]
you